[Applause]
it's hard to keep a relationship with
you guys are being so busy
um it's a little hard it's all about
trust and he loves me and I love him and
we just try to work it out
[Music]
well these are the power and the magic
moments of a career
we come for the performances and we
stand the fashion Secrets behind some of
the most iconic looks we got them
straight from the designer themselves
Katy Perry had four outfit changes it's
a bit like a Russian doll you know you
have to have things under things so that
you can kind of hide them because she
has no time to go backstage I always
have aces up my sleeve
200 man hours we had three uh sewers on
deck at all times working on these
we're just making sure that everything
is is secure and
a little sex appeal is okay I don't
think there's anything wrong with that
[Music]
Shakira's boots had 30 000 Swarovski
Crystals and cost 20 grand to make JLo
had four outfit changes including this
Versace number which reportedly took 400
hours to put together
[Music]
meanwhile Lady Gaga opted for just two
looks ensuring she wouldn't have a
wardrobe malfunction we go through an
extensive amount of training so that I
can sing and dance at the same time for
the show for 13 minutes everything is
going to be nice and tight for the game
I wouldn't worry about that
foreign